( banjo music playing )
Ooh...
I think I left most
of myself in there.
Uh, I'm telling ya.
I was seeing stars
at one point.
I always tell people
no one stinks up a bathroom
like my brother Skeet.
I'll tell you what.
That's what
I tell them.
What!
Don't mix those two things.
It's very explosive.
I'm sorry I yelled at ya.
I know you got
the blinks now,
but we've gotta get
this batch right.
If we can do that,
we can move out
of this dump
and move into where
dreams comes true.
Yeah, that's right, Skeet.
Good-bye Kansas City,
Kansas.
Hello, Kansas City,
Missouri.
Hmm.
We'll go fishin' like
we used to, right, Skeeter?
That's right, Beck.
And we're gonna be using real
fishin' wire this time.
Oh, that's right, Skeet.
Oh, our best days
lie ahead of us.
What!
Holy Moses.
What the hell?
Oh, my God, Beck,
don't look down.
What? Why?
What, ah,
I got no damn arms!
Yeah, it seems like
they come up missing.
I can still
go fishin', right, Skeet?
Sure, sure you can.
Uh, yeah, we'll
go fishin' still, yeah.
I mean, we could still kick
possums around the coal mine.
You don't need no arms for--
for possum kicking,
do you, Skeet?
Yeah, I suppose you don't
kick with your arms, yeah.
Hey, listen, pumpkin.
I'm gonna go put
these in some ice
and call an ambulance,
all right?
No, they'll put us
in jail for sure.
I'll just use
this here towel
to stop the bleeding.
No, Becky Lee!
Oh!
Oh, jeez.
Beck, where are ya?
Skeet?
Holy Moses.
I can't seem to
feel my legs, Skeet.
That's ‘cause you
ain't got none, Beck.
Oh, makes sense then.
Well, we can still
do all those things
we talked about,
right, Skeeter?
Uh, yeah, sure, sure.
I guess you could
put my torso
on a log by the creek.
And I could sing
one of my good songs?
Sure, we can do all that.
Your torso's gonna
see the world.
It sure is, Skeet.
What are you doing now?
I need to
cauterize the wound.
No, Beck!
We're gonna make it,
right, Skeet?
That's right, Beck.
Hey, how ‘bout ya
sing us one
of them good songs?
( both )
♪ Possum bleeding
on my torso ♪